بفعل الزلزال ام الانسان من بيت احلام الى
ما يشبه فتات البسكويت بطعم الموت من
المسؤول عن انهيار مباني حديثه في تركيا
بعضها لم يسكنها اصحابها سوى لشهور يتحمل
هذا المقاول ومئات من امثاله وزر الحصيله
الكارثيه لهزه ارضيه ارتدادتها غير
الطبيعيه ستستمر وقتا طويلا وثقت كاميرات
المراقبه في مطار اسطنبول لحظه اعتقاله
كان يحاول الهرب الى الجبل الاسود وبحوزته
مبلغ مالي هو مقاول مجمع سكني فخم فيها
تاي كان يسميه الجنه سكانه عاشوا جحيمًا
بعد انهياره منهم من فارق الحياه ومنهم من
وجد نفسه في العراء لا اثر لدعايه المجمع
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي والمواقع مثل
اغلب الاعلانات التي كانت تتباهى باستخدام
افضل انواع مواد البناء
واحترامي المعايير المضاده للزلازل لا
وجود لها حذفت مع سقوط تلك المباني بمن
فيها كاوراق اللعب حسب وزاره البيئه
التركيه نهز عدد المباني التي انهارت او
تضررت بشده بسبب الزلزال خمسه وعشرين الفا
حجم الدمار الهائل زاد من غضب الاتراك
الذين يطالبون بملاحقتي ومحاسبتي كل مسؤول
عن ذلك باشرت وزاره العدل العمليه انشات
مكاتب خاصه ضمن مكاتب المدعين العامين في
المحافظات العشر المنكوبه ذكر وزير العدل
التركي تفاصيل في اعلانه عن الخطوه
فتكون المكاتب مسؤوله عن اجراء التحقيقات
العدليه بشكل قانوني وتحديد المهملين او
المستغلين او المستخدمين للمواد الرديئه
حتى اليوم جرى التحقيق ودراسه ملفات 134
مشتبها بهم وايقاف ثلاثه منهم واعتقال
سبعه اخرين ومنع سبعه من السفر الى الخارج
باع
تراف واداره الطوارئ في لندن كانت قوه
الزلزال عنيفه ولكنها ليست كافيه بالضروره
لهدم مباني شيدت حديثا اين يكمن الصدع
الذي هوى بكل هذا العمران خلال الثواني
على الورق شددت انقره معايير البناء في
اعقاب الكوارث الطبيعيه السابقه يعود اخر
تحديث لها الى عام 2018
ضمن تلك الشروط استخدام خرسانه عاليه
الجوده معززه بقضبان ثلاثيه لمقاومه
الزلازل ويجب ايضا توزيع الاعمده والحواجز
لامتصاص تاثير الزلازل بشكل فعال على
الارض تطبيق تلك القوانين يبقى ضعيفا ومن
اسباب هذه المشاهد المرعبه منها تاي الى
ديار بكر وكرمان مراش وملاطيا الغش في
مواد البناء يتحدث المهندسون عن النوعيه
الرديئه للاسمنت المستخدم يمزج مع من
الماء والحصى وقليل جدا من الاسمنت هناك
ايضا نوعيه قضبان الحديد التي قد تكون
رقيقه جدا ولا يمكنها دعم الاعمده تكسر
الاسباب ومصيبت هؤلاء واحده منهم من يضطر
لمشاهده عشرات الجثث بحثا عن قريب
الله بعض الجثث دفنت بلا شاهد يذكر اسماء
اصحابها مرت ايام ولم يتعرف احد عليها
فوجب اكرام الموتى تمت التصدع كبير في سوق
البناء بتركيا ترميمه ضروره ملحه لتفادي
ماسك اخرى